تابع اياكم هنا هذا
المنزل لعائله التلباني في
مخيم المغازي وسط بطع غزه ارتقاء عدد من
الشهداء سحب بس حبه حبه
نشيله
السجاده تشال هذا
الشهيد شيل عقبال بعض يا شباب شيل عقبال
بعض
حتى هذه اللحظه تواصل يعني فرق الدفاع
المدني والاسعاف والطوارئ يعني انتشالها
للمصابين والجرح والشهداء في مكان الحدث
يعني من جديد يثبت هذا الاحتلال عن جيته
وفاش ته في استهداف المنازل الامنه على
رؤوس ساكنيها ذون سابق انذار يعني هذا هذا
المخيم شهد عده استهدافات وهذا الحي الذي
نحن نتواجد فيه شهد عده استهدافات خلال
الساعه الاخيره كان يعني من بينها استهداف
منزل عائله اسماعيل في المزل المجاور
والذي خلف عدد من الشهداء والمصابين
هنا افتحي ا صح هذا الشهيد جديد عباره عن
كون
الاش شيه
شسم نص
الخيه في
جسد
الشهيده هذه الشهيده
قد وجدها طواقم
الاسعاف في جهاز الدفاع المدن هذه النافذه
حيث تم العثور عليه ولا يوجد يعني مكان ل
انتشال جثمان الشهيد الا بهذه
الطريقه